le cortège commence tout juste à arriver
auprès des habitants
on résistera des milliers de personnes
ce sont réunis devant les mairies
comment Lauren à Metz ou une
Marseillaise a été entonnée en soutien à
tous les élus
[Musique]
ces derniers jours ont été les pires de
ma vie
pourtant face aux épreuves
je veux retenir le positif ça fait une
semaine que le procès a lieu sur les
chaînes d'infant continue que de toute
manière le procès il est plié la
condamnation elle est faite les
politiques utilisent les mots assassinat
pour certains d'autres disent que c'est
une excusable les mots meurtres
exécution je ne comprends pas l'immense
majorité des gens des quartiers
populaires avec les quelques centaines
de délinquants les quelques milliers de
délinquants que nous avons vu souvent
très jeune ce qui pose d'autres
questions très franchement de vous à moi
si demain vous attrapez votre gamin qui
descend dans la rue pour brûler des
véhicules de police ou les caillasser
des pompiers ou plier des magasins
la méthode c'est quoi ces deux claques
et au lit les parents qui ne
s'intéressent pas à leurs gamins qui les
laissent traîner la nuit en sachant où
ils vont aller quand ils ont 13 14 ans
ils ont cours deux ans de prison ferme
et 30000 euros d'amende selon un premier
bilan 1000 bâtiments ont été brûlés ou
dégradés 250 gendarmerie au commissariat
attaqués la semaine dernière la RATP
annonçait à avoir déjà répertorié plus
de 7 millions d'euros de dégâts je sais
pas si vous avez vu les images on entend
des jeunes rire rire quand ils brûle
c'est ce bus qui sauve la vie de leur
maman
je trouve ça absolument
nous relevons la tête nous faisons face
sans détourner le regard nous reprenons
la parole pour que la majorité jusqu'ici
silencieuse puisse se faire entendre et
dire STOP ça suffit et si le pillage
avait avoir avec la pauvreté les marques
avec le sentiment de la relégation
peut-être est-ce analysé politiquement
pas justement sécuritairement et vous
lui avez répondu par ces mots très crus
mais ferme ta [__] il n'a pas incité
Naël
c'est-à-dire qu'il leur attache même pas
à lui pourraient dire j'ai détruit parce
que Naël est mort rien ils disent ouais
je sais pas oui j'ai fait ça oui c'est
normal elle est où la normalité enfin
laxisme ça suffit vous avez pété un
plomb je commenterai pas mes propos je
vous laisse le faire moi je ce que
j'aimerais qu'on voulait retirez pas ce
que j'aimerais comprendre c'est pour
vous les retirer ce que j'aimerais
comprendre c'est pourquoi est-ce qu'une
une élue de la République appelle la
violence quand elle dit finalement là
les problèmes sociaux c'est un de ces
twits précédents la seule solution c'est
la violence le pouvoir politique voici
ma thèse ne contrôle plus la police dans
le syndicat majoritaire s'exprime de
cette manière c'est la police qui fait
peur au pouvoir problème de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon et de ses amis c'est que
depuis maintenant de nombreux mois
et à chaque fois qu'un événement se
produit qui justifierait que on fasse
montre de responsabilité qu'on convoque
des propos qui permettent d'apaiser le
pays au contraire ils organisent la
confrontation de tous contre tous ils
ont peur d'une troupe qu'ils ne contrôle
plus et qui est elle l'auteur de ces
débordements ils l'ont fait en
expliquant que j'étais à l'origine
personnellement d'une loi qu'ils ont
appelé permis de tuer et qui aurait été
la cause de mon tragiques qui sont
produits à long terme c'est un mensonge
une manipulation la jeunesse chers
collègues vous en fait de la chair à
canon pour les envoyer dans nos rues non
ça c'est la rue
de cagnotte ont été mises en ligne
celles pour aider la famille de
l'adolescent a déjà rassemblé plus de
160000 euros l'autre pour soutenir le
policier emprisonné des bassins millions
100000 euros il y a un symbole très fort
là-dedans les Français en ont puisse
applaudir admirer encourager soutenir
que tout ce qui les détruit que tout ce
qui est contre eux une attraction de
Carrow et un parc américain visité par
Jérémy Wagner qui a découvert un gros
problème sur la structure
une énorme fissure sur l'un des pylônes
elle est portée par Jean Messia ancien
porte-parole de la campagne d'Éric
Zemmour alors certains comme le premier
secrétaire du PS s'indigne contre le
site hébergeur et dénonce une cagnotte
de la honte la sécurité du parc qui a
rapidement fermé le manège des travaux
sont en train d'être effectués une
catastrophe a sûrement été évitée